[Music]
greetings to my 3abn family and welcome
to another 3abn today Bible q a
my name is Ricky Carter and I'll be your
host and I'm thankful that we can be
here with the Bible students
where we're going to be discussing
your questions that you sent in we're
going to be going to the Bible to find
the answers from God's word amen and let
me introduce you to our panel to my
right we have Pastor James Rafferty
welcome Pastor James so good to be here
Ricky love this program love answering
questions and I learn amen amen me too
me too and next to him we have sister
Shelly Quinn welcome sister you know
what I love about it is it makes us
think we have to to it helps solidify
the truth in in our lives as we study
your questions amen amen and next to her
we have brother Daniel Perron welcome
brother thank you I'm happy to be here
because I know that when we ask a
question of God he's going to answer it
amen amen he will he's promised that
well before we hear these answers why
don't we go to the God go to the word
through prayer and brother James
rasterity could you pray for us please
absolutely thank you that's great father
thank you so much for this opportunity
that we have just to connect our hearts
to heaven and to ask for the promised
gift of your Holy Spirit you promised in
John 14 16 that you would send the
spirit to teach us to instruct us to
convict us to be our comforter and we
just pray that for ourselves for our
audience for every person that sent in a
question we ask for your Divine guidance
thank you for your word thank you for
hearing us and answering as we pray in
the name of Jesus Christ amen amen amen
well Pastor James I've got your first
question but before I share that with
you I want to share with our viewers how
they can participate with Bible q a
first out of the three different ways
the first one you can do is you can
email us at
bibleqa at
3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv the
second way you can send us your
questions is you can text us at
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 and then for those of you
who are on Instagram you can send us
your questions at 3abn underscore
official that's at 3abn underscore
official also have you heard about our
new website yes we've got a new website
it's 3abn
bibleanswers.com where you can find a
lot of your questions are on this
website there's questions you can find
the answers to these questions like what
happens when you die or questions about
the second coming or questions about the
biblical Sabbath you can find all those
answers and many more at that website
3abn bibleanswers.com
all right Pastor Rafferty yes got your
first question for you all right
as a child of God what can I do to
strengthen my faith and get closer to
God that's from Christine in Maryland
and she texted that question to us that
Christina is a great question that is a
basic question that every one of us need
to ask how can I get closer to God how
can I have a stronger relationship with
God there are a couple verses I want you
to look at the first one is found in
Romans chapter 10 verse 17. this is my
go-to verse on this question Romans
chapter 10 verse 17 why what does it say
it says faith comes by hearing and
hearing by the word of God you've asked
the question how can I strengthen my
faith well faith comes by hearing and
hearing by the word of God so how do we
strengthen our faith through the word of
God well there are several ways we can
do that number one just studying and
reading the word of God every day when
you get up you just open the word of God
and you begin to to absorb it to take it
in to read it to ask questions about it
to praise God if you if you when you
read the promises that are in that verse
for you to compare that verse that
you're reading or that section that
you're reading with other verses other
sections of the scripture to see if you
can gain a better understanding better
insight into the scripture and the
verses there and then I find that when
we spend time
on something we spend time thinking
about something you know a lot of times
we can waste our time maybe you know in
the media social media and I find that
we don't only waste the time in social
media but a lot of times the things that
we watch in social media we end up
thinking about later on we put it in our
brain and there it is later on well it's
the same with the word of God not only
do you want to study the word of God and
read the word of God but you're going to
find yourself thinking about what you've
been reading and studying maybe you're
out in the garden or you're going for a
walk or you're driving the car and you
could be thinking about what you read or
what you studied or a point or a
question that you might have so there's
study and then there's meditation you
read you study you meditate and then you
want to listen listening to the word of
God is one of the main ways that I get
the word of God into my brain I'm
listing the word of God in audio I'm
listening to the Bible I'm listening to
spiritual uh preachers and teachers who
are spot expounding the word of God
preaching uh preachers preachers who are
exposes the word of God and then Ricky
you're going to love this one there is
song right there is song and if you go
on YouTube You're Going to find Ricky
and you're going to find a lot of the
scripture songs that he's put to music
on there and you're going to be able to
put the word of God into your mind
through song A lot of those scriptures
that come back to you when you need them
have not I commanded you to be strong
and have a good courage that's the one
that I listened to just recently Ricky
Right Joshua 1 9 and then you want to
memorize the word of God when you
memorize the word of God when you sing
the word of God when you meditate on the
word of God when you listen to the word
of God when you study the word of God
when you read the word of God guess what
happens as a result
your faith gets stronger your faith
grows you don't need a lot of faith
I just need the right kind of Faith
Jesus said if you have faith Luke 17 is
a greater Mustard Seed you've got the
faith that can move mountains and that
faith comes by hearing and hearing by
the word of God amen amen thank you
brother
all right sister Shelley yes I've got
your first question you ready ready all
right
I believe there is one lesson God wants
us to take from the Bible and that is to
love
across the Bible God displays how much
he loves us am I wrong in thinking that
the thing above all that God and Christ
want for us is to love and if I'm not
wrong did you think this is what we
should be focusing our hearts and lives
on that's from Roland in California and
rolling Instagram that to us well and
thank you for such a wonderful question
you were right first John 4 8 says that
God is love this is a self-sacrificing
love not a Sentimental love it is
something that God has demonstrated in
actions particularly in becoming a man
and dying for us first John 1 5 says
that God is light in him there is no
Darkness this is talking about his
righteous character so how important is
love listen to the words of Jesus Mark
12 30 and 31 you shall love the Lord
your God with all your heart with all
your mind with all your soul and with
all your strength this is the first
commandment Jesus said and the second
like it is this you shall love your
neighbor as yourself there's no other
Commandments greater than these now what
Jesus is talking about is an agape love
you and I can't do this on our own we
have to go to the Lord Romans 5 5 said
he sheds his love abroad in our hearts
by the holy spirit so we have to ask
to
have that
self-sacrificing love poured into our
hearts by the Holy Spirit and then we
will become like Jesus John 14 15 Jesus
said if you love me obey my Commandments
and I will pray the father get this
that's a connector there love me obey my
Commandments and if you're doing this I
will pray the father he will give you
another helper that he may abide with
you forever so if Roland you're talking
about love
being motivated to be loyal to God to
walk in obedience motivated by love it's
the most important thing and that's what
Jesus is saying love is the highest
expression of worship from God and it is
the pathway to His blessings Romans 13
10 says love does no wrong to one's
neighbor it doesn't hurt anybody
therefore love meets all the
requirements of the law it is the
Fulfillment of the law
love the Lord your God Commandments one
through four love your neighbor as
yourself commandment six through ten of
the Ten Commandments
let me add this first John 2 3 and 4. by
this we note that we know him
if we keep his Commandments but he who
says I know him and does not keep his
Commandments it's a liar and the truth
is not in him here's my favorite
scripture on love first Thessalonians 3
12 and 13.
Paul's writing to thessalonica church
and he says may the Lord make you
increase and abound in love who's doing
the work it's God working in you
and then he gives the purpose so that
he may establish your heart's blameless
in Holiness before our God and Father at
the coming of our Lord Jesus Christ do
you want to be blameless in Holiness
then you need to go before the Lord and
say Lord fill me with your love because
his love is a self-sacrificing love and
more you grow in that love the more you
will grow in Holiness and be separated
from sin so yes love is important we
just need to understand the definition
of it amen thank you very much sister
all right brother Daniel I've got your
first question you ready all right here
we go
I believe in God and have faith in God
when difficult situations come up I say
that God will take care of them however
in my mind I wonder what if God doesn't
take care of it how do I handle this and
what would
what would my unbelieving friends think
all right well I know that everyone here
at this table has been in this situation
where we have to step out in faith not
seeing the end from the beginning and
putting our trust in God and people are
watching
and the promise that I hold on to in
this situation is in second Corinthians
5 7 and it's a promise it says for we
walk by faith and not by sight that's
not just a description it's a guarantee
that walking by faith God will not let
us down and so this is the invitation to
each of us to step out in faith and that
means obedience to God's will regardless
of where it leads but sometimes we do
ask Lord will you come through Lord
people are watching and there are
several different situations three here
that I want to talk about where this
where this happens in our life and one
of them is situations of our own
causings where we've been impulsive
perhaps or presumptuous or disobedient
and I think of Joshua chapter 7 when the
Israelites have gone up to attack the
little town of I and God was not with
them in this and 36 people died so
Joshua fell in his face praying before
God and he says in verse 9 of chapter 7
the Canaanites and all the inhabitants
of the land will hear it then what will
you do for your great name so the Lord
said to Joshua get up why do you lie on
your face Israel has sinned now God had
not left them but the question must be
asked Lord am I doing my will or doing
your will the second situation though is
the complete opposite and there's so
many stories like this where God has
asked you to obey in faith and I take
you to Exodus 14 where the Israelites
are gathered at the Red Sea verse 15 of
chapter 14 and the Lord said to Moses
why do you cry to me tell the children
of Israel to go forward
so if you've prayed about it and you've
sought Godly counsel and you've
confirmed God's word with your God's
instruction with his word then go
forward and I'm sure that there were
people of Israel as the water was
lapping around their ankles who were
wondering what if God does not come
through and so in that situation we
asked the same question Lord am I doing
your will or am I doing mine and if we
know God has asked me to do this I'm
doing what is right then we go forward
because this is what matters am I doing
what God wants because that's the best
thing for me and the third situation is
where God is glorified by our
perseverance even when things don't work
out as we may wish or as we may expect
in Philippians 1 verse 12 Paul says but
I want you to know Brethren that the
things which happen to me have actually
turned out for the furtherance of the
gospel and this is what God is doing
behind the scenes God knows the end from
the beginning and he knows where our
perseverance and our faithfulness and
our calm trust and our unshakable Joy
actually becomes a blessing to others so
in all these things how to handle it is
the same Lord I want to do your will I'm
going to go forward regardless of what
my friends or what others who are
watching may think I'll pray for them
but I'll leave those results in your
hands amen amen thank you very much
brother
okay pastor Rafferty I've got your
second question okay and this is your
opportunity to give us a four minute
answer super
can you please explain how Jesus died
the second death but didn't go to the
Lake of Fire that's from Michael who
sent this to us as a text message from
Wisconsin all right Michael that's a
great question you know the specific
phrase second death is found only four
times in the all the Bible and those
four times are all in the last book of
Revelation now two verses describe those
who will not be hurt by the second death
and then the other two verses describe
those who will experience the second
death which is the Judgment of God
against sin now the first two references
are in Revelation 2 verse 11 and
Revelation 20 verse 6. those are
positive in relation to the second death
and then the second two verses are found
in Revelation 20 verse 14 and Revelation
21 verse 8 and there's a negative about
the second death only one of those two
verses actually describes the second
death as the Lake of Fire so there are
four verses and only one of those four
verses describes the second death in The
Book of Revelation as the Lake of Fire
so
let's just read those last two verses in
relation to this question if Jesus took
our death did why didn't he suffer the
Lake of Fire so Revelation chapter 20
verse 12 Revelation chapter excuse me
Revelation chapter 20 verses 14 verse 14
contexts verses 12 and 13. and I saw the
dead small and great stand before God
and the books were opened and another
book was opened which is The Book of
Life and the dead were judged out of
those things which are written in the
book of in the books according to their
works and the Sea gave up the dead which
were in it and death in Hell delivered
up the dead which were in them and they
were judged every man according to their
works and death and hell were cast in
the Lake of Fire this is the second
death
and then verse 8 of Revelation 21 8 but
the fearful the unbelieving the
abominable the murderous whoremonger
Sorcerers adulterers Liars all liars
shall have their part in the lake which
burns with fire and brimstone which is
the second death now that doesn't say
Lake of Fire but the implication is
there in that uh second verse that we
read so the context of these verses
describe the second death as a judgment
against sin we're stepping into the full
context here there's a judgment that's
coming against sin and those who've
refused to let go of sin so the question
we really need to ask is did Jesus
experience the judgment
described as the second death in
Revelation chapter 24 20 verse 14 in
Revelation 21 8 did he experience the
Judgment against sin in other words
was Jesus judged according to our works
was Jesus charged as an unbeliever was
he charged as a liar as a murderer said
did Jesus become sin for us as it says
in second Corinthians chapter 5 and
verse 21 and the answer is yes it's
important to note that while the second
death is described as the Lake of Fire
in Revelation chapter 20 it is also
described in other places of the Bible
in different terms than the Lake of Fire
Revelation 20 is a summary of Revelation
The Book of Revelation is a summary of
the rest of the Bible the rest of the
Bible helps to expand upon the
experience of the second death so let's
take a look at a few of these other
places you know we noted only the Book
of Revelation describes the second death
in terms of the Lake of Fire but
Revelation borrows from the rest of the
Bible for example the second death is is
described in terminology like cut off or
uh forsaken or cursed
um in verses like Matthew 24 51 and
Psalm 88 verses 5 and 8 and in Daniel 9
verse 26 so we see that phrase these
phrases used to describe the same
experience forsaken is another biblical
term in relationship to the second death
according to Psalm 22 verse 1 and cursed
is yet another biblical phrase and
that's used in Galatians chapter 3 verse
13. all of these phrases are used to
describe the experience of the second
death and Jesus Christ is described as
being forsaken of God being cut off
Jesus Christ is described as being
cursed of God so when we look at all of
the Bible in relationship to the second
death and recognize the second death is
described in these other terms in other
parts of the Bible that then we can see
how Jesus Christ tasted the second death
and that's the key phrase there he
tasted the second death that's how the
Bible describes it in Hebrews chapter 2
and verse 9. amen thank you Pastor
Rafferty for your answer amen all right
sister Shelley I've got your second
question here we go
I understand that we are to give 10
percent tithe and offering
is that supposed to be off our grossed
or net income that's from Claire and she
sent that to us via Instagram
Claire that's a great question and
here's a simple answer if you are a
salaried employee or an hourly employee
on your earnings you pay 10 percent on
your income if you are a business owner
a self-employed business owner you pay
10 percent well I shouldn't say pay you
return 10
on your increase for example if you are
making your cabinet builder let's say
and the cost of goods to build a set of
cabinets was nine thousand you sell it
for ten thousand you're going to only
tithe on the increase at that one
thousand dollar profit
so the question usually it comes down to
do we pay our on our income most of us
are salaried or hourly do we pay on our
income before taxes are taken out is
that the amount we should return our
tithe on or do we return our tithe after
the next the net and you know what
we're not sure the Bible doesn't really
tell most Seventh-Day Adventists my
church pay on their gross amount they
pay on the amount they earn before taxes
but the Seventh-day Adventist Church has
no mandate uh it is our choice we should
purpose in our hearts and discuss this
with the Lord because he's the one we
answer to
and I do want to make sure because I
think I messed up we don't pay our tithe
we return it amen because the 10th
Belongs to the Lord
it's like it's interesting it's like
he's trusted us with that to see if we
really have a heart to obey him but I
want to give you this one scripture
because to me it's the bottom line on on
tithing Malachi 3 10. the Lord says
bring all the tithes into the storehouse
that there may be food in my house
and then he says something so
fascinating he says try me in this this
is kind of like not saying I dare you
but it's like saying I double dogged
here you know he said try me in this
and he said
it says the Lord of hosts see if I will
not open for you the windows of heaven
and pour out for you such blessing that
there'll be no room to receive it God is
saying I want you to know this is a
principle this is my money the tenth
Belongs to the Lord return it to me in
faith go ahead and and you know what he
says I will rebuke the Devourer for your
sakes
every Miracle starts with a step of
Faith so
obedience is the pathway to God's
blessing try him in this and see how God
makes that 90 percent go a lot further
amen amen
all right brother Daniel I've got your
second question this is a fun one
when were the dinosaurs here
all right dinosaurs raise a lot of
curiosity because they're surrounded in
some mystery all we know about them
comes from the fossils and the fossils
don't talk to us we just know what those
fossils that they were dead and now
they're here and the word dinosaur is a
modern word it doesn't exist in the
Bible and so everything that we can
learn about them comes from our
understanding of scripture and our
knowledge that comes through the fossils
and I want to tell you that the
existence of dinosaur fossils does not
conflict with our faith in the word of
God so here's what we can know Genesis 1
verse 21 says God created great sea
creatures in every living thing that
moves with which the waters abounded
according to their kind and every Winged
Bird according to its kind all right any
flying creatures God made Genesis 1
verse 25 says and God made the Beast of
the Earth according to its kind cattle
according to its kind and everything
that creeps on the Earth according to
its kind so the first biblical statement
here is that every a living creature was
created by God on day five or six of
creation and man was also created on day
six of creation so just because the
Bible does not list dinosaurs by name
does not mean that they were not a part
of God's creation neither were dolphins
or lions listed by name and just because
an animal appears strangely formed to us
doesn't mean that it wasn't a part of
God's creation there's lots of strangely
formed animals out there but there's a
lot more to this story here Genesis 1
verse 30 says also to every beast of the
earth to every bird of the air into
everything that creeps on the earth in
which there is life I have given every
green herb for food and it was so so
whatever these dinosaurs were intended
to be God did not create them as
ferocious beasts to tear others apart
and there were plenty of vegetarian
dinosaurs uh paleontologists can tell
that by their teeth but God created them
to be vegetarians Genesis 3 verse 14
says so the Lord God said to of the
serpent because you have done this you
are cursed more than all cattle and more
than every beast of the field every
creature that God has made has suffered
because of sin and we know that the
implications of this are that their
biological changes that have taken place
due to sin and the changes are exerted
over time Genesis 3 14-19 indicates that
there are biological changes in the
serpent in childbirth and even in the
plant kingdom and so we know that small
changes even tiny changes in regulatory
genes can exhibit physiological and
anatomical changes in species and so
what we know is that the fossils if we
as Christians we understand that the
fossils were most likely created during
the great flood and so the evidence that
we have of these dinosaurs is about 2
000 years removed from creation so
they're not in the form that God
intended them to be so this is what we
can understand from the fossils in God's
word is that these animals were given
Life by God and at some point they
became extinct and they lived there
right alongside with man for a while
amen amen thank you very much brother
great answer all right Pastor James yes
got your third question here
if Michael stands up once Daniel 12 1
why do people teach probation closes
twice
once for the church and once for
everyone else
I've heard pastors say when the Sunday
laws are passed the church's probation
closes Yet Michael stands once that's
from a viewer or listener in Florida and
they texted that to us okay that's a
great observation this is a teaching
that has been around in the Adventist
Church for quite a while it's based on
two Bible verses first Peter 4 17 in
Ezekiel chapter nine and uh you are
correct Michael stands up once probation
closes once there is one General close
or probation now that doesn't mean that
individuals can't close their individual
probation before that time and many
times people will close their probation
they'll commit the sin against the Holy
Spirit and they'll be completely
impregnable to the influence of the word
of God and the truth of God's word but
there's only one General close of
probation however when you read First
Peter chapter 4 verse 17 it says for the
time has come that judgment must begin
at the house of God and if it first
begin with us what shall be the end of
those and Obey not the gospel of God and
so an idea has been developed based on
the scripture and Ezekiel we'll look at
that in a little bit that there's the
house of God and then there's the rest
of the world and in a sense it's true
that there's the house of God and
there's the rest of the world but not in
a sense of the church versus other
Christian churches or other Christians
there is those who profess faith in
Christ and that would include every
single person across denominational
lines that professes faith in Christ
versus those who do not and do not obey
the gospel in other words there's a
judgment for those who profess faith in
Christ and then the Judgment we call it
the executive Judgment at the end of the
Thousand Years for everyone else so
there's one General judgment and there's
one General close of probation now
Ezekiel chapter 9 is a little trickier
but it's still just as valid it
basically is talking about in symbolic
language these angels that come into to
the city of Jerusalem a symbol of God's
Church God's people in the end of time
and again this is
um you know a symbolic prophecy so it's
not easy to follow but they come in and
they have these these weapons these
swords and then there's one Angel among
them that has an acorn and this Angel
Goes Forth to seal all the people in
Jerusalem in the church that are crying
and saying for the Abominations that are
done in the land and then the destroying
Angels follow and they slay everyone
that does not have the mark now that
Mark or seal is the Seal of God it's the
same thing that's talked about in
Revelation chapter seven and the
slaughtering angels are symbolic or
represent representing the seven last
plagues that's key the seven last
plagues so what we have here is we have
the Seal of God being acted out in this
symbolism we have the ceiling synonymous
with the Judgment that judgment takes
place when the test comes to all the
world a lot of people are going to leave
the the truth in that time a lot of
other people are going to replace them
come into the church come into the faith
everyone's going to be sealed and then
the seven probation is going to close
Michael's going to stand up and The
Seven Last flakes are going to fall it
doesn't take place at the Sunday law
because let's just say the Sunday law
takes place tomorrow we still have to be
tested and it's going to take a few
weeks even a few months for God's Church
to be tested on whether or not they'll
stay faithful during this time of Sunday
law and while that test is going on a
lot of people leave the church but every
place that's made vacant is going to be
filled up by those coming into the truth
and then finally the sea will be affixed
to those who remain faithful to God Amen
thank you very much Pastor nice complete
answer there all right sister Shelley
I've got your third question and here's
your opportunity to give us a four
minute answer it's good
let's hope
which Israel is Paul referencing in
Romans chapter 11 verse 26. that's from
Ben in Texas and he texts texted that to
us okay then in Texas
I've got to explain something up front
because if I don't people are going to
be screaming replacement Theology and it
isn't it's biblical Revelation theology
when the Bible speaks of Israel some of
us are very close-minded as to who
Israel is where did the name Israel come
from what is the origin of that name in
Genesis 32 or excuse me 28 12-15
Jacob has a vision of the latter God is
renewing the Covenant of Abraham and
Isaac with Jacob and he gives Jacob
a covenant name later as he he says to
him in as he is wrestling with God
Genesis 32 28 he says your name shall no
longer be called Jacob but Israel this
is after he struggled with God through
the night for you have struggled with
God and with men and have prevailed
so we've got the Covenant
person of Jacob he's a covenant keeper
he struggles with God God gives Jacob a
covenant name this is a spiritual origin
none of the Patriarchs were Jews they
were all Hebrews the Jews did not exist
as a nation yet so
but because Jacob's name is Israel the
Bible talks about the sons of Israel his
son's going down to Egypt and then they
became a nation in Exodus 4 22 the
nation becomes known as Israel God says
say to Pharaoh thus says my Lord the
Lord Israel is my son my firstborn said
now that spiritual name goes from Jacob
to the nation
then this is exciting in the second
servant song There's four what they call
it's a poetic term servant songs in
Isaiah they're all about Jesus Christ
the coming messiah in the second Psalm
it's clearly this is Isaiah 49. the
context is referring to an individual
not to the nation it's a soliloquy it is
actually the second person of the
godhead in heaven speaking prophesying
about what is going to happen when he
comes to Earth as the person of Jesus
Christ and is incarnated as the
preeminent Son of God
and he says Isaiah 49 3. he said to me
he's speaking of himself you are my
servant o Israel in whom I will be
glorified many people think that's
referring to the nation of Israel God
was just about done with the nation of
Israel at this point I mean they they're
getting ready to go into Babylon they
couldn't please him
it is
the second person of this of the godhead
who's going to become Jesus Christ up
lies the term Israel to himself
he's
Jesus is the one who really struggled
with God and prevailed he prevailed
victory over the devil so here's what I
want to say
Jacob's sons
became known as the sons of Israel
Christ followers become known as Israel
Galatians 3 29 if you're a Christ you're
Abraham's seed and there is according to
the promise Romans 2
28-20 he's not a Jew who's one outwardly
Noah's circumcision that which is
outward in the flesh but he is a Jew
who's one
inwardly and then Galatians 6 16 says
that God will be merciful and have peace
upon the Israel of God so Romans 11 26
when Paul sang All Israel will be saved
he's just got through finished talking
about you know till the fullness of the
Gentiles and everything and he's also
just got through saying in hope that
some of the Jews will be saved but
Romans 11 26 he says all Israel will be
saved and he's speaking of New Covenant
Believers who become the sons of God the
Covenant sons of children he's speaking
of spiritual Israel amen amen thank you
sister
brother Daniel I have your third
question but before I give you that
question I want to share with our
viewers at home how they can participate
with Bible QA
well first out of the three ways the
first way you can participate with Bible
QA is to email us at bibleqa at
3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv or
you can text us at
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 and then for those of you
who are on Instagram you can send us
your questions that way at 3abn
underscore official that's at 3abn
underscore official
all right brother Daniel and your
question you have an opportunity here to
give us a four-minute answer
here we go I heard a pastor say that
Jesus name is Yeshua and that means
Joshua in English some say that his real
name is Jesus would you please explain
that's from Laura in Missouri she texted
that to us okay thank you Laura for this
question I like to be called by my name
and I like to call people by their name
and I want to do the same for our savior
is there a true name that we should use
when we are addressing or describing him
the name Jesus is a transliteration or
an anglicized English spelling of the
Greek name Jesu which is just the uh the
Greek form of the Hebrew name Joshua
which means God Saves and so we see
already here that there's a language
issue behind this Jesus is not a
different name but it is a way of
presenting who he is in a way that is
understood to people think about John 1
14 where it says the word because came
flesh that God himself came down in our
form took on our flesh so that he could
be understood by us there is not an
exclusive language that God authorizes
to use to address him think of First
Corinthians 14 10 that says there are
many kinds of languages in the world and
none of them without significance and I
think of Acts 2 when the gospel is being
preached by the apostles people heard at
each one in their own language and so
Jesus precedes all human language and so
regardless of the language you speak we
think of John 1 12 that says as many as
received him we're not receiving a name
a set of letters but we're receiving a
person who is our savior so a name is
more than just a combination of letters
your name is your character and we can
find this throughout the Bible I just
want to give you two texts here Proverbs
22 1 a good name is to be chosen rather
than great riches it's not about a good
set of letters but about your character
who you are Revelation 14 verse 1
describes the 144 000 as having his
father's name written on their foreheads
it's not just once again about correct
letters on your skin but about having
God's character imprinted upon you
Abigail got it right speaking about her
husband nabal whose name means fool in
first Samuel 25 25 for as his name is so
is he talking about his character so
Jesus and Joshua were both common names
of the day you can look it up in a
concordance there are four different
joshuas mentioned in the bible there are
at least three different jesuses
mentioned in the bible so how do you
know if someone were to say Joshua which
one are they referring to it's not
because the letters are the same it's by
the character Yeshua Jesus of Nazareth
Yeshua Joshua son of none same letters
what's the difference it's who they are
their character and so Jesus has many
different names and here's just a few
and we should become familiar with all
of them because each of them tell us who
he is Matthew 1 20 name call his name
Jesus because he will save his people
from their sins in Matthew 1 23 call his
name Emmanuel same person new name
sharing more about him Isaiah 9 verse 6
his name will be called wonderful
counselor Mighty God Everlasting father
Prince of Peace all names for Jesus
Genesis 49 verse 10 he is called Shiloh
and in Matthew 16 16 Jesus affirms Peter
for calling him the Christ and says
flesh and blood has not revealed this to
you but my Father in heaven and Jesus
himself used son of a man to refer to
himself more than any other name or
title so there's not just one name
the New Testament writers are not wrong
for calling Jesus Jesus when Paul said
in Philippians 2 10 at the name of Jesus
every knee shall bow they're not talking
about specific letters Paul is talking
about who he is and so if you have
received Jesus then you have received
eternal life there's no power in
syllables there is power in Jesus in who
he is have you received him amen amen
praise the Lord thank you very much
brother
all right Pastor Raffi do you have your
have your final question here
I know the Bible says that no one knows
the hour of Christ's return not even the
son so why are there people predicting
the time of Christ's return the Bible
says there will be prophets prophesying
his return I wrote a story about one in
Colorado who said Christ would Rapture
in 2011. some preachers are telling
people that 2027 is the Lord's coming
the Bible says even the elect will be
deceived is this all correct I think we
are in the time of Revelation 14 through
17. please help and that's from Shirley
in Wyoming and she texted that to us
Shirley Wyoming that is a great question
that you have and a great statement I
think time setting is kind of like a
certain form of malaria that you can get
that if once you're infected if you're
not properly treated it will reoccur
again and again and again and I have
been in contact with lots of people who
once they get into a 4 form of time
setting we've had the Jubilee cycle
we've had Y2K we've had the main
calendar even a time setting that's
based on the number of popes since 1929.
there are a lot of different forms of
time setting once you get it in your
blood and I want to say a seven-day
Adventists we are our movement started
with a time setting if you will a 2300
day prophecy that predicted that Jesus
was going to come in 1844 we
misunderstood not the prophetic section
of that but the event itself the
cleansing of the sanctuary which
actually did not refer to the Earth
being cleansed at the same coming of
Christ but the Heavenly Sanctuary the
most holy place and the second portion
of ministry there in heaven and since
that time
we've continued on a lot of times
Adventists are more susceptible to this
I think than anyone else I've talked
with a lot of people who focus on these
different types of Cycles these
different events the 1927 or the 2027
date again is based on some ideas about
when Christ was baptized he was 27 years
old I mean I I don't want to go into the
details because again it's just another
form and I think it's going to continue
on I remember praying please Lord let
there be another Pope please Lord let
the man count the past please God let
why 2K pass I just remember praying
those prayers so that people might be
more susceptible but it seems like when
one of these events passes another one
takes its place the only way that we can
really get focused uh get out of this
and get focused on what God is actually
waiting for is my a deep study in the
word of God there are several Bible
verses that I think you could share with
your friends who might be into this the
first one is found in second Peter
chapter 3. second Peter chapter 3 verse
12 specifically says that we need to be
looking for and Hasting under the coming
of the day of God wherein the heavens
being on fire shall be dissolved and the
elements melt with fervent heat and in
the context of that it says seeing all
these things what manner of persons
ought we to be in other words God is not
waiting for a specific time he's waiting
for a people he's waiting for a people
who are
fulfilling the promise of the mystery of
God in us now that's Revelation chapter
10 verse 7 it's first uh Colossians
chapter 1 verses 25 26 and 27 Christ in
us the hope of glory is what God is
waiting for Jesus says it this way in
Matthew chapter 24 verse 14 he says when
this Gospel of the kingdom is preached
as a witness now a lot of people say
when this gospel is pre of the kingdom
is preached in all the world no no it
doesn't say that as a witness the
witness part the mystery of God part
um the the manner of persons that you
ought to be part is the critical part
and of course Revelation 14 says the
same thing lasting gospel going to Every
Nation Kindred time and people producing
the people who keep the Commandments of
God and that again Shelley mentioned
earlier is the love of God in our hearts
that causes us to keep his Commandments
and have the faith of Jesus that's what
Jesus is waiting for he's not waiting
for a time to be fulfilled or an event
to take place he's waiting for us to
perfectly reveal the character of Jesus
Christ in our lives then he's going to
come
us as his own amen amen thank you
brother
all right sister Shelley here's your
fourth and final question okay are
Jewish people still saved because they
are heirs to Abraham even if they don't
believe in Jesus that's from Kim in
Maine she texted that to us Kim I hope
you heard my answer a while ago on
Romans 11 26 because when Paul was
talking about all Israel would be saved
he was speaking of spiritual Israel God
does not or Paul never teaches Universal
salvation it is always about those who
are in Covenant with God through Christ
Jesus Jesus said this in Luke 3 8.
therefore he's speaking to the Jews bear
fruits worthy of repentance and do not
say to yourselves we have Abraham as our
father the Jews thought because Abraham
was their biological father okay we're
saved but he says I say to you that God
is able to raise up children to Abraham
from these Stones so only you know the
Everlasting Covenant of righteousness by
faith you mentioned II Corinthians 5 21
that Jesus became sin he who knew no sin
became sin for us he took on our sin to
pay our penalty dying on the cross that
we might become the righteousness of God
in him so when we are in him when we are
following him he is the one that shed
the blood of the Everlasting Covenant as
Hebrews 13 20 says but as we are in him
following him that's how we will be
saved so Abraham is the father of us all
Paul says in Romans 4 and verse 15.
Abraham is the father of biological Jews
and spiritual Jews as well but he is
especially the father of all who enter
into Covenant Revelation 15 excuse me
Genesis 15 6 when Abraham believed God
it was accounted to him his
righteousness but then he comes right
around in chapter 17 it's about maybe 14
years later he says to him I am the Lord
your God walk before me and be perfect
so
what the Bible tells us acts 4 and verse
12 salvation is found in no other name
there's no other name under heaven
given among men by which we must be
saved we have to understand
that we can have Assurance of Salvation
only if we are in Christ if we've
entered into Covenant with God if we are
walking in his ways following the
righteousness of Christ's footsteps
first John 5 11 gives us this promise 11
and 12. it's this is the testimony that
God has given us eternal life this life
is in his son he who has the son has
life he who does not have the son he who
is a biological descendant of Abraham a
Jew that won't accept Christ he who does
not have the son does not have life only
Jesus can deliver us and give us eternal
life amen amen thank you sister
all right brother Daniel is your final
question
how can I make sense of the commandment
to honor thy father and mother when a
parent is not a good parent but toxic
that's from Jacqueline in Florida she
texted that to us thank you Jacqueline
and this is a good question and you can
apply these principles in all your
relationships and honoring your parents
is going to look different at different
stages of your life but I think here's
one text that can be helpful Matthew 5
44 where Jesus speaking in The Sermon on
the Mount says I say to you love your
enemies bless those who curse you do
good to those who hate you and pray for
those who spitefully use you and
persecute you and so number one I'd say
be willing to forgive and put things in
God's hand forgiveness is how God deals
with us and invites us to extend that to
others and then pray for your parent and
see them as God does and recognize that
that God wants you to desire their
salvation you can't change another
person but you can through God's grace
change how you see them and then the
transformation of your heart may become
an agent to transform theirs
you can honor your parent by
strengthening your own relationship with
God because when you do that then you
let your light shine and and that light
might be the very thing that that helps
them God desires for your parent to be
clothed with his righteousness and to
dwell with him forever and as you draw
close to him you then extend that to
others I would say choose your words and
your actions carefully to say Lord I
don't want to say anything that's going
to hurt my parent sometimes I want to
enact revenge or or vindictiveness or
sometimes say something to hurt them
spitefully and commit yourself by God's
help to speak only words of love and
kindness to that person and then it's
okay to set boundaries you can honor
your parent by saying I I keep my
distance and the void that is created
there you fill with Christ because he's
the one who is the support the source
and the supplier of your love that you
can extend to others the bottom line is
that Jesus loved us when we were
undeserving and by God's grace then we
can do the same to others and that gives
glory to God and it honors your parent
as well amen amen
well you've heard all those wonderful
answers from the word of God hope you
are blessed by that we're going to take
a short break so don't go away because
we're going to be right back
if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3ab in Bible q a for answers from
God's word
welcome back thanks for joining us
before we go we're going to get some
final thoughts from our panel Pastor
James I just wanted to touch on the
second death you know Jesus survived the
second death because he himself did not
sin and the grave could not hold him
permanently yet Christ's Resurrection
from the second death is not evidence
that he didn't experience the second
death the biblical evidence is
overwhelming that he was judged in our
place that the power that was brought
against him is is the power that is
brought against the wicked that he
experienced that judgment that hurt that
wrath of God for us in our place amen
Iran sister Shelley
um I just wanted to expand a little on
the heart of God he wants all men to
turn to him and be saved he the Bible
repeatedly says that God wants all to be
saved that's why he's so patient with us
there will be people in heaven that may
never have heard the name of Jesus but
will accept him because they've been
seeking God all their life I'm not it's
not up to me to judge who's going to be
in heaven I just know that it's harder
to be lost than it is to be saved amen
and brother Daniel in my last question I
dealt with honoring parents and I want
to address little kids just for a moment
here Paul does say in Ephesians 6 to
that children should obey their parents
in the Lord and the reason for that is
that when we obey our parents it teaches
us to obey God but not all parents
fulfill their role there and Jesus does
give a warning to parents who don't
fulfill that rule but there's a promise
for you in Psalm 68 verse 5 that says
that God is a father to the fatherless
amen amen
well thank you for joining us I want to
leave you with this fun scripture song
you shall love the Lord your God with
all your heart with all your soul and
with all your strength do Deuteronomy 6
verse 5 God bless
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]